the market square is a popular meeting
place in Vemma many famous people were
at home here the Renaissance painters
Lucas Cana the elder and younger lived
in this building but it's mainly the
classicists from Lima that attract many
visitors to come here that's weird I
kinda know my dad gets plenty of it no
let's stroll a bit further we invite
more love to just amble along Vemma is a
city for pedestrians the sites are close
together the architecture reflects the
city's feudal days that's why this is
democracy square it used to be called
first in plots or Dukes square that's
very fitting because it's surrounded by
royal buildings gaben frustation kapoy
there are the so-called red and yellow
palaces than the first house where Duke
Charles Augustus lived and next to it is
a small palace that's been a library for
centuries the Dowager Duchess anna
amalia whose name it bears supported the
library decisively many treasures are to
be found here and there's a first
indication of johann wolfgang von goethe
presence in the city he ran the library
for decades
right next to it the park on the inn was
created in the 18th century it's
renowned for its valuable trees and
architectural gems like the ruins of the
template on house good also played a
part and designing the park he spent his
first years in Vemma in this house call
oak was sudden thesis house King Charles
Augustus gave him this house as a gift
because he wanted good to stay in vimar
as a homeowner good to was eligible for
citizenship of I'm are and Charles
Augustus was sure good to would remain
in the city for a while so he achieved
his name after 1782 good who lived in
this house on phone plan many of its
rooms look the way they did in the last
years of the poet's life the study in
which he wrote works such as Faust is
unchanged good estate in Vemma until his
death in 1832 for good to hurt us Italy
part of its charm for Gerta was
certainly that it wasn't too big but it
was manageable it also provided him with
a political sphere of activity in
addition to poetry and literature
Angelica fides
good as interests were many and varied
he was a poet government official
dabbler in science and traveller he
wrote for nature's like mine a journey
is invaluable it animates corrects
instructs and develops
the composer funds list spent many
summers in this house in a bunt an
infant list had a close friendship with
Grand Duke Charles Alexander and the
Grand Duke managed to get him to return
to home are and what's the best way to
do that give him a house would be Mothma
dad's am besten munching in main house
here the celebrated musician taught
young gifted pianists from all over
Europe for free the Nexus that's your
our next stop is the Bauhaus University
in 1919 the architect of otago pious
found the Bauhaus art school in viman in
architecture art and design the school
followed a clear formal vocabulary free
from the elements of historicism that's
even visible in the Bauhaus universities
hallways
but why did the avant-garde architect
come to Vima hopeless constantly here
all tingly gropius came here because
Goethe had been environment because it
all began with that Golden Age righteous
Goethe and Schiller but also had her and
be blunt and he wanted to continue that
tradition Hamada hang up I'd pulled US
forces it's the Bauhaus later did that
in des el the next stop is worth for
additional lived an assembly brought
Schiller and Goethe together good start
by instagood to get into a conversation
with Friedrich Schiller and was
fascinated so he invited Schiller to von
maur by my god from that moment and
intense creative association existed
between them by aidan an intensified
shuffle spoons vemma classicism can be
traced to the Dowager Duchess anna
amalia who lived in the widow's palace
she was a very well educated and
ambitious woman
she hosted illustrious social gatherings
they're among the guests were of course
guten Sheila who now attract attention
as a memorial in front of the National
Theater via border gizumon here people
sang and made such music that the angels
in heaven were truly delighted that's
the angle mhmm ooh you have evolved
avoid it's fun happy and I hope you've
been delighted by our city tour through
my my thank you for your attention and
goodbye Thanks open up some kind of